hey what's going on is pill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday February 10 2010 what's going on
how are you a [ __ ] piece of fuzz of
my goddamn windscreen here why don't you
why don't I have a windscreen
you know inside the house in case you
turn on the air conditioner huh you're
[ __ ] warm freckled [ __ ] there how's
your life how's it going I I don't have
[ __ ] to talk about this week everybody
so you know why don't we let you go
first
I actually have a few things to plug
here Oh bill Oh Billy
Bonzo face here I'm going to be playing
drums on the Dean Del Ray Dean del rey's
Bon Scott tribute it's gonna be March
10th at 7:00 p.m. here in Hollywood
California at the Avalon you can go to
Avalon hollywood.com for tickets it's
going to be the usual Rock star-studded
lineup I don't know who I can announce
who I can't announce I don't know yet as
the date gets closer now the last time
we did this was a couple years ago and I
got to jam with Nikki Sixx and Michael
Devon and Scotty and all these amazing
people Dean always brings him out last
time before that was like Rudy Sarzo all
kinds of amazing players and you know
people always think that it's you know
oh they're gonna do a stand-up show
first which we are and then there's
going to be some half-assed like [ __ ]
rock show afterwards it's it's an
incredible stand-up show and then the
rock show afterwards just it's just
[ __ ] unbelievable it was the first
one was incredible the next one is even
more amazing and then this one I talked
to a few people that I think are coming
down you know busy people people torn
and [ __ ] trying to make it happen but
it's going to be [ __ ] insane be there
March 10th 7 p.m.
Avalon in Hollywood Dean Del Ray's Bon
Scott tribute it's been 40 years since
one of the great front men in rock
history Bon Scott unfortunately passed
away prematurely
so anyway you know plowing ahead plowing
ahead what the hell do I want oh and
also I got nothing to buy me and well
Billie promo here the bill Bert podcast
episode 4 dropped last week episode 5 is
dropping next week as you can tell I
didn't write that copy because I don't
say drops I do say you know hit me back
when you get a chance I will say that
but I try not to go to [ __ ] young
person you know that's that's young
person [ __ ] by the way I posted
something cuz I was watching some of
that XFL very little but I was watching
it and I've always been a big fan of new
leagues and rooting for them because I
missed the AFL and I missed the ABA and
I missed the WHL and the only thing I
got to see was the USFL and I went to a
game the Boston Breakers versus the
Washington Federals at Nickerson Field
and was sold out by the way and but by
then the NFL was just so established
that there was really nothing that could
[ __ ] with it and I was looking at the
XFL and I was I you know as a few unlike
the Dallas renegades their helmet is the
[ __ ] so all I do is I [ __ ] I try to
screen grab whatever the [ __ ] kids
call it and I just posted it onto my
Twitter and the amount of [ __ ] that I
got [ __ ] the amount of [ __ ] that I got
was ridiculous all I said I go they got
a sick [ __ ] logo there you stole it
from the Ottawa renegades I look at the
Ottawa one there's some similarities
except theirs stinks and Dallas's is
awesome so if they stole it from you
they [ __ ] took it to another level
let's not act like Ottawa pulled that
thing out of their ass a [ __ ] demon
looking cowboy with a bandana over his
[ __ ] nose didn't they steal that from
every spaghetti-western that Clint
Eastwood was ever in sorry how do you
get a drink of water oh I got my got my
[ __ ] blood go god forbid you say you
like something
it was just overwhelmingly negative
everybody was saying was awful then
people just sitting there going like
that
in uniforms I feel like I'm watching
like I don't know what like a any given
Sunday it's like if you really look at
the NFL a lot of their uniforms look
like something you'd see on any given
Sunday you're just used to it okay I'll
start with my team the New England
Patriots terrible uniform terrible logo
terrible colors that silver with the
blue and the red I [ __ ] hate it I
like it because I associated with
winning and when they go back to the old
[ __ ] you know Paul Revere
you know bent over getting the [ __ ]
ball on the side of the helmet with the
red jerseys I look at those and I get
sick to my stomach because I think
they're you know I go back like any time
Tom Brady would wear it I'd be like take
that [ __ ] thing off you're gonna jinx
yourself
okay the Seattle Seahawks terrible
terrible [ __ ] uniform the Denver
Broncos you tell me these all don't look
like expansion franchises who else who
else is as a bad one Houston Texans the
[ __ ] the Titans all of those look
like just [ __ ] like I don't know and
then you get other ones that are just so
goddamn plain but you used to them like
the Vikings and the Packers and the
Bears they have like a history behind it
but if they just came out you'd be like
these are like the lamest like this is
like when I first got a computer and
they and they discovered emoji so people
would be [ __ ] all over those two so
I love a a random league going up and
I'm not mad at watching football twelve
months out of the year you know and then
a new league always has like some cool
rules I saw this little guy kicked the
[ __ ] ball out of bounds on the
kickoff after a score and they put the
ball on the team that kicked it off they
put it on there 45 yard line so
immediately it was this massive massive
[ __ ] I like when they do [ __ ] like
that and their overtime is each person
gets like the ball like either four or
six times rosie was telling me and you
try to convert six out of six
two-point conversion sorry there wasn't
watching the Oscars downstairs which is
the perfect time for me to do my podcast
and it is a perfect time because I won't
get into a fight because whenever I
watch award shows I always get into
fights with Nia because
I just watched it on TV and I make fun
of it and and she really really loves it
she's really into it so I got to make
sure that I don't ruin it for because
they were downstairs
my mother-in-law everybody's over right
so I was downstairs I poked my head and
you know and they had all the you know
the poor [ __ ] women right on the red
carpet just starving themselves for
weeks on end you can see their ribcage
all the way up to their [ __ ] larynx
right everybody on a is dressed up like
they're nominated for something it was
[ __ ] hilarious and I just felt bad
for because then everybody picks him
apart and all that type of [ __ ] and I
was really sitting there looking at it
and I finally just said just started
curiosity because they because they were
[ __ ] on this one woman's dress
saying it was the color of bile whatever
color that is right and then another
woman comes out it's the exact same
[ __ ] fabric and they love that one so
I just said you started curiosity what
is the difference between that dress and
the last dress other than the color and
the you know my mother-in-law laughs cuz
she's the coolest person ever right but
the look that I got from all the you
know chicks they're my wife's age and
younger that generate they all looked at
me night and I got that's like a [ __ ]
Jeanette and that up there the [ __ ]
Vera Wang it's like all leather so and
then the next person that shows they
showed some movie star guy who's wearing
a tuxedo it's like oh my god now that is
a bowtie that's another great thing
about being a guy you just throw in the
[ __ ] tuxedo they don't they have no
[ __ ] idea whether you went down to
[ __ ] Teddy's tuxedo or you actually
bought some I mean I would I wouldn't
think right it's [ __ ] great being a
guy is great and that's why women are
constantly [ __ ] bitching constantly
you know what I mean it all comes down
to us no matter what they're complaining
about just know and in the back of their
head they know that if your wife knows
that if you were walking on red carpet
all you'd have to do is take a shower
and shave and throw on the same [ __ ]
tuxedo every other guy has and you will
not be judged just lay off the booze for
[ __ ] seven to ten days and you're
gonna look like a million bucks
and the [ __ ]
1,200 miles of [ __ ] that a woman has to
go through to try to look her best
seeing stars puking behind dumpsters
just to have some [ __ ] guy you know
[ __ ] tear the [ __ ] out of you it
really is a thankless job so I came up
right as the right is the the thing
started and Janelle Monae was out there
and she came out dressed as Mister
Rogers and I have to say as a white
person I was offended with that reverse
cultural appropriation okay Mister
Rogers was white okay let's not black
wash white history all right then I got
upstairs I was like a waiter and then
they make a movie about it there was a
documentary that I saw so maybe that was
a nod to that because it probably got
nominated cuz I think it was really good
I don't know I don't [ __ ] know but um
I think it's gonna be another long night
of people making everything about
themselves I want to thank the Academy
and as a you know a [ __ ] left-handed
hermaphrodite with the speech impediment
I just want to say you know it's gonna
be all of that
it's like you got an award the problem
you're making millions what is the
problem what it is is you got to say
something crazy or else you just get
lost in the shuffle I get it like I
don't even think half of those people
are serious it's just they're trying to
get as much as they can out of that
moment they don't give a [ __ ] about the
dolphins right they don't give a [ __ ]
about one-legged little people living
under bridges whatever the [ __ ] their
causes what they care about is that
their speech is going to go viral so
with any luck you were touched funny as
a little person right as a kid and you
can go up there and you can tell that
story because you know that the band's
not going to start playing
if you
if you start telling his story about get
in touch for there's a strategy to this
okay if you just go up there and just be
like man I can't up let me I never would
have thought a million years I'd be up
here and the only reason why I'm up here
is because of a zillion other people's
hard work editing and putting music
underneath me and and and the people who
wrote the stuff that I said god bless
all you because I'm getting the victory
but it's you know it's really you guys
if you just say that that then net
speeches is never going to exist you'll
never see it again you'll see it on
boring calm the next day but if you
[ __ ] go up there and talk about how
you lost a toe to diabetes when you were
at a rally to save [ __ ] I don't know
[ __ ] one of those frogs what I was
trying to think that [ __ ] TCU come on
frogs what are they the horned frogs
trying to save horned frogs you lost a
[ __ ] toe some [ __ ] like that some
about global warming okay being a victim
of a creepy guy some sort of disease any
of that [ __ ] you got to work that into
your speech or just just you're gonna
get lost in the zeitgeist did I use that
word correctly I always say that word
when they talk about [ __ ] like that so
anyway they're downstairs watching that
[ __ ] and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
do my podcast right and then I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna slip away all right
play a little drums and then I'm gonna
go out and go do a [ __ ] spot that's
what I'm gonna do and why I'm not really
slipping away she knows that's what I'm
doing and she also knows that that's
where I'm supposed to be
there's sort of an unwritten rule when
that shit's going on when this [ __ ] that
she really likes like when the Sex and
the City girls get together again and
they make another [ __ ] movie and she's
renting it and her friends are
downstairs watching it I know that that
is my cue to hit the [ __ ] bricks to
beat it right you got to do that because
you got to understand that's your wife's
you know Super Bowl the Super Bowl
football watching sports it's all [ __ ]
stupid all right but it's not stupid to
you cuz you're into it
does that make sense I mean how [ __ ]
thumb is it speaking of which you know
there was a lot of backlash about the
[ __ ] the halftime show at the Super
Bowl you know what I mean
and what I loved was like how come J
Lo's getting [ __ ] and that [ __ ] guy
for maroon5 didn't it's like because she
went way further both of them were
wildly inappropriate for like a football
game when there's kids there I agree
with with with people this is one of
these things weren't oddly conservative
I don't anything conservative like it's
[ __ ] weird to be doing sexual [ __ ] to
an audience that has children there you
know what I mean
to come out there all shirtless and
grinding your [ __ ] dick and all of
that [ __ ] what I listen in defense of
Adam Levine I didn't watch the halftime
show I'd [ __ ] plow through the [ __ ]
right but like j.lo me come on you just
because there's a bunch of women going
like how come it's like well if Adam
Levine shaved his privates and then put
a piece of duct tape over him and
started humping a stripper pole I think
that that would be you know you know
there's all different levels of theft
right there's there's there's petty
theft this is [ __ ] grand larceny
oh what a whole bunch of dip I don't
what the [ __ ] they are sit here and act
like I have a goddamn law degree but I
will tell you this the halftime show at
a Super Bowl is when you when you go
sexual like that
it's [ __ ] bizarre but JLo show in a
middle of a football game was as [ __ ]
bizarre is if you went to Vegas to see
JLo show and then and she for 20 minutes
she went back to take a break and then
all of a sudden they played football on
the same [ __ ] stage like the [ __ ] am
i watching here
having said that I think there's bigger
fish to fry out there and I don't think
that many people were offended by it but
I I would never say that somebody who's
sitting there with their kid if a
[ __ ] like 80
nine percent naked woman comes out in
the middle of a football game the
championship game by the way to like the
[ __ ] most watch game or like some guy
comes out like shirtless and it's just
sort of like you know all sweaty and
[ __ ] do whatever the [ __ ] he did yeah
that's like you you wouldn't do that I
don't know I think it's weird because
that's not your show okay you're doing
like it like like like a guest you're
doing a guest spot when the show is the
football game so you're doing a guest
spot so you know you should [ __ ] try
to act accordingly now if all those
people took their kids to your [ __ ]
rock show or your stripper pole show
then you know that's on them they can go
[ __ ] themselves right it's like people
get offended by a comedian right if you
go to a comedy club go [ __ ] yourself
right now if you hire me to do a private
gig and you go hey whatever you do don't
talk about XY and Z and then I go up and
I do it I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
shouldn't pay me that makes sense listen
I'm not trying to say somebody shouldn't
be allowed to get a Brazilian wax from
their [ __ ] [ __ ] to their baalbek
and go out there with no shirt on it
[ __ ] sing in a high-pitched voice
okay you can do that on you do that on
your toy alright we got kids here kids
like you know there's people in the
[ __ ] crowd that probably went to
Super Bowl 12 with their dad and now you
know then they brought their kid to
Super Bowl 25 and now they're you know
now you're a grandfather and you're
going to the gut you know and when they
came up it was just like it was like a
college band would just go out in the
field you know what bad but bad bad bad
it's all it was anyway plowing ahead
plowing ahead there's nothing wrong okay
with football there's nothing wrong with
maroon 5 there's nothing wrong with the
Brazilian chick or JLo okay it's just
you know it's like there's nothing wrong
with orange juice and there's nothing
wrong with brushing your teeth but if
you do one right after the other it's a
kids it's not a good thing all of a
sudden it becomes annoying
having said that for all the feminists
out there I hope you win the right to be
able to walk around shirtless I hope you
[ __ ] yeah I hope you win that one you
know let us guys know what's up right
take that there's my titties huh you
think you're running [ __ ] take a look at
those [ __ ] Tatas and I love it too
because I feel like it cuts women's
power in half because it cuts their
power to half because so much the power
that a beautiful woman has you know you
can't even talk when you're around them
you make dumb decisions you know you
start [ __ ] you know kick so you know
they got your house right and all I
gotta do is show a little bit of
cleavage and smell a certain way and
you're gonna make some of the dumbest
decisions of your life now but if you're
walking around looking at titties all
the [ __ ] time and then she comes in
with her titties out it's like really
not that big a deal
so now what they're gonna have to show
is they'd have to show like either ass
or clam cleavage you know to get you to
get rid of your house so I think that
that's a good one I think that's good
for everybody women can feel like you
know they have the same freedoms as guys
and then guys can feel a little more on
on on level ground when they're they're
dealing with a beautiful woman who's
using like her beauty to try to
manipulate you into doing something that
you know if you really sat down and
thought about it if you could rub one
out real quick and then you know you
know he had you little clear head there
you wouldn't do it
am I crazy hey I think me and Bert
Kreischer are gonna go to the opening uh
Los Angeles Wildcats they could have
come up with a better [ __ ] name then
how many Wildcats are there are there
are any Wildcats in Los Angeles there
you know what they should have done they
should I just wish that you know it's a
[ __ ] expansion league they should
have just gone for it you know what I
mean there's two ways that I would have
I would have gone either humor I would
have gone straight up ethnic I don't
know why ethnic does not mean white
people but for whatever reason it
doesn't like I got to make sure this is
not an offensive word before I say this
but I would just dial in to one
non-white ethnicity I'd either go black
or Latino
I think I go Latino because I think
they're underserved in in professional
sports I'd go after that market and then
they would build their whole [ __ ] fan
base around that and it would be too
cool for the mainstream to [ __ ]
ignore and then you'd pull in the white
people that way okay here we go all
right what is this a cholo is that an
offensive term a man have been did
indigenous or partly indigenous ancestry
a young informal a young man belonging
to a Mexican American urban subculture
associated with street gangs al so maybe
that's a bad thing because I would say
youth like the Los Angeles cholos right
you could fill the void of the Raiders
losing you'd give rate of fans something
to do during the offseason they would
immediately have this tough [ __ ] vibe
instead of just going Wildcats may have
ever the [ __ ] team is out there is
that right unless that's offensive I
don't know I have no idea but I would
have gone that way instead of just be
like the Wildcats or you go the other
way and you stare into white Hollywood
culture you could I can't say trophy
wives because any kind of saying
everybody on the team's a [ __ ]
well what's what so what's interrogates
a term for a [ __ ] guy the playboys
the at Los Angeles playboy Zetas have
some it's just the logo right you got
some guy some guy of a certain age with
his shirt opened down to his navel who
should who should be really wearing a
[ __ ] turtleneck with some young
brought in his [ __ ] arm and then you
get all these [ __ ] and ejecta firing
women all the time
I love how that's like objectifying
women and then you leave a woman up to
her own [ __ ] powers and she's gonna
shave her [ __ ] himself and put a goddamn
piece of duct tape and hump a pole fair
enough
something like that like I really
thought like you know I really thought
that the Vegas nights I really thought
that they they could have come up with
something a lot better than
that the degenerates but what's let me
see let me see sound like for gamblers
let me see something here it's so funny
they sit down they act like they're not
into gambling you know they've been the
[ __ ] gambling you [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright let's see here
synonyms for gamblers what do we got
here sitting in forego a backer a
stacker speculate a risk-taker the Vegas
risk takers too long Vegas back the
Vegas stackers yeah and you got two
stacks of [ __ ] chips and some guy
with a stogie smiling I mean it's I
don't know it's a lot that's pretty
involved in the logo something like that
the betters a plugger a punter the high
rollers the Vegas high rollers come on
you know what it is it's no matter how
new the league is is it still gonna act
like a corporation in corporations fish
commercially that's what they do it's
commercial fishing so they're gonna try
to well you don't wanna offend people
like the fact that MLB doesn't call the
Devil Rays the Devil Rays anymore
because a couple of Jesus freaks didn't
like that Devil was in the word I mean
in the team name it mean it's literally
the name of a [ __ ] stingray right I
mean I have no idea one of my [ __ ]
Jacques Cousteau anyway so I'm going to
the LA Wildcats vs. the the Dallas
renegades whatever the [ __ ] name
there is you know that I guess they
stole from the Ottawa renegades who
really stole it from us because we're
the [ __ ] Cowboys all right
not you [ __ ] Canucks up there with
you goddamn snowshoes driving the
indigenous people to the top of the
[ __ ] planet as you for some reason to
have this reputation for being you know
all these like the super nice white
people you know you know what I don't
buy it
Canada is like one giant Utah
[Music]
you know it's like really nice but this
is creepy underbelly and you can't quite
put your finger on it you don't you just
know something happens and I always
think of poltergeists you know you moved
the headstones
but you didn't move the bodies remember
that one of the great
Craig T Nelson's for the great [ __ ]
lines in 80 cinema history I [ __ ]
love that I love the delivery of it I
love the whole thing all right all right
bill we get it you love things you love
things I also loved you know it was
[ __ ] hilarious overnight when ivory
posted the picture of the Dallas
renegades aside from everybody [ __ ]
on it somebody goes this is exactly how
a Boomer posts a picture right which I
[ __ ] love I love that for some
[ __ ] reason
Generation X doesn't get any [ __ ]
whatsoever we just sitting there laying
in the cut I believe as the young kids
say right just sitting there right not
getting [ __ ] for [ __ ] anything we're
all in our 40s and 50s at this point we
got to be running some Bank out there
that's doing some [ __ ] bad [ __ ] it's
all if it's not boomers its Millennials
and they're just sitting there yelling
at each other I'm [ __ ] I'm loving I'm
loving every [ __ ] minute of that man
oh my god
speaking of the 80s loving every minute
of it love a boy turn their doubt that
was the 80s people were too coked up to
take the time to write lyrics that
really meant anything right and that
opened the door for a band called
loverboy goddammit you know and I've
always maintained that the lead singer
may or may not have been Dan Marino I'm
not sure all right
anyway how about those Boston Bruins how
about your Boston Bruins huh six in a
row I think they just came up a four or
five game road trip what every goddamn I
think they won every game since the
[ __ ] all-star break
I only so I've been keeping up with them
but I only I watched I watched him
against the desert dogs they're the
Phoenix Coyotes Phil Kessel
former Bruin former maple leaf two-time
Stanley Cup winner in Pittsburgh has now
brought his services down there to
Phoenix he's having the perfect career
he was in a cold city went to an even
colder city and then dialed it back down
again and now he's just like you know
what I feel like I'm in you know second
half of my career here I'd like a little
more sunshine after a nice morning skate
happy for him he had a nice power play
golf but I was also more happy that we
won the brusk
I feel is really [ __ ] turning into
something that's gonna be special for
the Bruins Djali Coyle believe you some
Weymouth Wagner's from Walpole mass and
[ __ ] loving this team you know all we
got to do when missin is we got to bring
some enforcer up from the goddamn - all
right and the next time we play that
[ __ ] st. Louis Blues we get we got it
or the [ __ ] Columbus Blue Jackets
with that Claude Lemieux looking the
other way and accidentally punch and
tuka in the head oh I'm sorry I didn't
see that how do you accidentally give
somebody a concussion get the [ __ ] out
of here
yeah we need somebody that's gonna make
people pay for taking liberties there if
you don't want to mean we need somebody
brave oh my god it's time for
advertising brave everybody uh you are
living in the surveillance economy what
in God's name does that mean we are
currently living in this surveillance
economy what it what is that you might
ask I did Jesus Christ
genius copy every time you download a
web page you are not just downloading
the content text and images you are also
downloading privacy invading trackers
many popular media sites have over 100
trackers on every page and I always
wondered do voyeurs enjoy this do they
get the same sort of that rush that
they're being watched if they're just
online or do they have to be like
brushing their teeth you know with one
ball hanging out of the bottom of their
jock in front of an open window sorry so
what you might ask you
your digital profile includes
information about usage age your search
and watch history your personal beliefs
or even your location everywhere you've
been or even your current GPS
coordinates there's a way to protect
yourself and remove the surveillance
economy start using brave brave stops
data grabbing trackers and creepy ads
from following you across the web which
allows you to browse up to six times
faster than with other browsers here's
an important fact about us brave isn't
anti Ed's
brave is anti tracking brave users can
choose up to opt in to brave ads a
privacy respecting ad network run by
brave brave never sees your personal
data or your behavior let alone sells
that information for profit you'll never
see an ad from brave unless you
explicitly choose to participate with
brave ads you can earn rewards for any
ads you choose to view that's right
out-of-the-box brave will block ads and
trackers but you can choose whether you
want to see it how often they appear and
get rewarded for your attention if you
click one on one sorry how does brave
money work if you choose to opt in and
brave ads brave takes a cut of the
advertising spend weight kind of the
advertising spend whatever you choose to
view an ad I feel like there was a word
missing brave takes a cut of the
advertising spend whenever you choose to
view an ad that's how brave earns money
and keeps the browser free it takes less
than 60 seconds to switch the brave
import and your bookmarks with one click
and start enjoying a better internet
listeners of the mmm podcast can easily
switch to brave today go to brave calm
slash burn and download brave today
that's brave dot-com / / switch to day
to day today and then we got one other
one oh it's helix here HELOCs okay
here's my helix ad I'm Bill burr I'm a
real you know they wrote this for me
people there they're writing it as
though I'm saying this okay let's hear
what they think of me hi I'm Bill burr
so far I agree with this
I'm a really unique guy oh Jesus that's
why you like my podcast oh my god or
don't like it I don't care yes I do I
wouldn't be doing it I'm a people
pleaser but I'm truly one-of-a-kind
which is why I want to sleep on a
mattress designed specifically for me
and you can't - Jesus Christ like
advertising one on one what about our
product overlaps the the public persona
the brand that we're trying to connect
this with all right
but next please mention the talking
points below I'm gonna mention for all
you people who advertise on the podcast
whatever you write I'm gonna [ __ ] say
it
alright so you don't need to [ __ ]
tell me you don't need a wag your
Madison Avenue index finger at me I'm
gonna read the [ __ ] all right
he looks sleep built a sleep quiz that
takes two minutes to complete and they
use the answers to match your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you if you like a mattress
that's really soft or firm you sleep on
your side or on your back or your
stomach or you sleep really hot gross
with the HELOCs there's a specific
mattress for each and everyone's body
everybody's unique taste just go to
helix dot-com / / take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life hellix Leap was even
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2019 by GQ & Wired
magazine it's very easy to get in one of
the other very few get in both those
magazines simultaneously during the same
year they have a 10 year warranty and
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free gross
they'll even pick it up if you don't
like it yeah that's pretty nice yeah now
if you get a guy doing the job right now
he'll exhale is offering up to $200 off
mattress orders for our listeners get up
to $200 off at hellix sleep calm /
burpee you are are all capitals well
there you go there's a lot of people out
there to have problems sleeping it's
probably your mattress because God knows
you know from what I've heard you know
after a couple years of sleeping on the
same mattress you know there's enough
[ __ ] extra skin laying around out
something gross it's ruled all
right who the [ __ ] knows we should
probably do it right all right I want to
thank everybody came out to Chumash
casino up in Santa Ynez I was gonna chop
up there but it's an uncontrolled
airport and there's not a lot of lights
and stuff like that so I decided not to
you see that everybody that's what I did
there I've been having a great a great
time getting ready for that gig though I
was doing I was doing stand-up and uh a
bunch of random rooms you know I usually
just go down to the comedy store and I
was just kind of feeling like you know I
don't want to go down there's so many
you know every every room is packed I
just want to go to some random rooms I
really feel like I need to lean on the
microphone stand and if I like like I
always do that anyways but I mean just
really just sort of work my way through
some [ __ ] so I did three random rooms
let's see I did one I think Wednesday
Thursday Friday was the gig oh wait no I
did Wednesday Thursday and then Saturday
I went to a place I usually don't go to
and I went into the smaller rooms and lo
and behold lo and behold it was it was
fun again and then I got to see a bunch
of young comics I'd never seen before
that will [ __ ] hilarious I don't know
and I feel like you get better and you
went away your act stays young being
around them without you even noticing it
because I've seen those guys when they
start selling tickets and they don't
come around to the clubs anymore they
just sort of age out with that with
their with their fanbase they get older
their fans get older and then you just
up there you know singing [ __ ] five
foot two eyes up you know doing the
[ __ ] senior circuit so I'm trying to
avoid that but I think I'm gonna be
doing a lot more of that and then I'll
miss the Comedy Store and I'll go back
I'll still do the Congress too I love
the Congress no but I'm just saying I'm
trying to put together there's a couple
of things that I've been working on and
want to work on and it just sort of
requires bombing and there's just so
many murderers that
store you know what I mean go up after
[ __ ] Joey Diaz I mean you got to
bring the lumber Joe Rogan
alright the Lee I mean they just it's
just one [ __ ] murderer after another
so it was nice to kind of go down there
and just try to work through some [ __ ]
they used to be a [ __ ] this theater
that I used to go to out here and of
course some [ __ ] rich [ __ ] bought
it and knocked it down it just sucks man
I love I used to go down there and Marc
Maron told me about it
speaking of [ __ ] beasts he told me
about it and he goes yeah man I just go
down there and he goes I don't take any
money you know they sell it out and I
just get to work out my [ __ ] and I'm
like that's [ __ ] brilliant so I
started doing it and thanks to him and
then you know what they did they went
out the Steve Allen theater they went
ahead and they [ __ ] knocked the
goddamn thing down oh dude I got a
[ __ ] hilarious story about that one
time I was I was I did a show down there
and I was coming out and I was as I got
into my car it was starting to back up
and drive away and there was just this
one lone fan left in the in the parking
lot like six other random cars there and
he was walking up to my car smiling and
he waved and I waved back to him and I
just drove away going what the [ __ ] was
that and in my head I was like you know
that kind of looked like so-and-so that
[ __ ] lunatic looked like so and stuff
like this guy that I knew and then I
went home and like two days later as I
checked my email and I had an email from
that guy telling me he was coming down
to the show it was him and he smiled and
waved to me and I smiled and waved to
him and I just [ __ ] drove away cuz I
thought he was just some psycho that
went to my show I didn't realize it was
and it was this guy that I'm like
friends with but like I don't see him
all the time so it wasn't like he could
just text me oh well I don't know it was
just it was [ __ ] hilarious and then I
ended up emailing him back and then he
never got back
then I finally ran into him he goes all
yeah I saw that was no big deal I
thought it was like pissed at me or
something but I just remembered that so
anyway you might be seeing me in some
random rooms over the next month working
on my [ __ ] I really been enjoying you
know now my acting working [ __ ] is done
I really just [ __ ] enjoy we're in
between seasons f is for family just
going back to doing what the [ __ ] I'm
supposed to be doing in this business
which is just being an idiot on stage
and I've been having a lot of [ __ ]
fun it's just it's the greatest [ __ ]
job there is whoever invented stand-up
comedy I am forever in debt and all the
people that [ __ ] kept it going before
me there's no way to have a thank them
it's the greatest [ __ ] job so I will
be [ __ ] around and some weird you
know Nova knows you might be out getting
a [ __ ] cheesesteak and all of a
sudden [ __ ] show starts and my dumb
ass will be up there huh anyway speaking
of that have any like [ __ ] lately I got
to stop I have to you know what happened
was I quit the [ __ ] cigar so the SI
gars so no no I got nothing man
so like I kind of went back to like
sweets and [ __ ] eating like [ __ ] like
once every other day just like one bad
meal which still isn't that bad but like
I gotta watch it here hey Billy you
gotta watch it okay you ain't a spring
chicken no more a'right
okay let's um let's do a little love
some little questions here here all
right bubble bath [ __ ]
dear baby back [ __ ] BRR okay I like
that one on January 27th Monday morning
podcast you said that you don't think
there is anything more boring than
taking a bubble bath but on January 3rd
a 30th Thursday afternoon just before
Friday
Monday morning podcast you go into great
detail about drawing a piping hot bath
after your acting gig sounds like you
really enjoyed it
what are you saying might hit you
finally figured out I'm a [ __ ]
hypocrite he goes so which one is it our
baths boring or were you able to change
your opinion over
course of three days I love the podcast
and I love your live shows
I see you in Chicago every opportunity I
get thanks and go [ __ ] yourself all
right well this is what happened to me
between Monday and Thursday on Wednesday
I had an acting gig as I went into great
detail I
yeah they had me running like TJ Hooker
for an afternoon you know which would
have been great in my 20s and in maybe
even into my 30s but at 51 yeah I came
home and I felt like I had [ __ ]
played
I wouldn't say tackle foot but I felt
like I played touch football in the
street you know and so I was enjoying it
is for the fact of being an old person
pouring epson salt in there but as far
as like if I wasn't sore Souza deal I
guess basically if my body is aching
because I'm old and I pushed it too far
I don't mind taking an epson salt bath
however my wife tells me I have to stay
in there for 20 minutes and I have to
tell I I will tell you after eight
minutes I am like I like this has to be
20 minutes and I look down it's like 8
minutes and 37 seconds and [ __ ] so I do
think it's boring you know and if they
could somehow just make the epson salt
work a little bit quicker I would
appreciate that so I could feel even
more privileged to live in this country
so that's that's what I would say it is
all right sir
so judging by your your your question
here I would say that you are a fan of
baths and I would never want to you know
shower shame you by telling you that
baths are boring so by all means these
[ __ ] goddamn can be update not
installed what the [ __ ] do I have to do
every [ __ ] goddamn three [ __ ] days
I I use so little of my [ __ ] computer
and what I hate is there's no like
that's what you you kept on details any
it off because it's like now in one hour
later [ __ ] off
unbelievable it's unbelievable how
just do not get prosecuted for
deliberately making [ __ ] obsolete with
all the [ __ ] environmental [ __ ]
problems right oh I know why I know why
it's not a [ __ ] problem because you
know they because they [ __ ] pay off
the politicians I will tell you what
will never cease to [ __ ] amaze me
though is regular Americans excited
about a president it just will never
never just like and to think you know
like when Obama was in all these [ __ ]
liberal idiots thinking that he was out
there working for them and then you see
Trump goes in he got all these [ __ ]
goddamn people out there don't have a
[ __ ] pot to piss in and they think
that he's gonna turn their [ __ ] life
around it said I just never [ __ ] it
never ceases to amaze me I don't want to
be negative here but guys you're on your
own
alright which is why it's such a great
thing as a regular [ __ ] citizen to try
and help out another fellow American
despite their [ __ ] political views
you just help them out because that's
what you should do as a decent human
being and unfortunately politicians are
that they're [ __ ] from day one they're
just so grossly underpaid and the only
way that they're gonna [ __ ] be able to
feed themselves and not die eating cat
food is if they blow these [ __ ]
corporations so that then they can then
go on the speech tour I'll tell you
what's gonna be [ __ ] hilarious is
gonna be the the Trump speech tour
that's the one I want US that's the one
that I want to see you know what I mean
the Obama one would just be annoying
because he would come off like a [ __ ]
hero and it's just like you did the same
filthy [ __ ] all the other ones did I
will tell you this I do like how George
W just [ __ ] disappeared like [ __ ]
it the [ __ ] I'm out I'm out see you
later
just hangs out and paints goes to a
baseball game with Ellen DeGeneres like
these doing it right guys get it figured
out
he's probably deep-sea fishing right now
there's gotta be uh what kind of a
[ __ ] calm down is that's gonna be
like it's got to be the day that you're
looking forward to most throughout most
of your presidency especially during the
difficult days but there has to be an
unbelievable [ __ ] letdown the day that
ends let's say you're a two-term
president for eight [ __ ] years you
never [ __ ] sat in traffic never a TSA
line you had to sit through you just got
on the [ __ ] plane took you wherever
you wanted to go right any musician
you're into would come over to your
[ __ ] house that you're living in for
free and do a private concert call you
mr. president I can't imagine it ac/dc
came over here and called me mr.
podcaster and it only lasts for four to
eight years and then it's just [ __ ]
over and then the rest of your life you
got to go out and give speeches to some
of the most heartless evil [ __ ]
people on the planet and you have to
talk to them like they're human beings
and you have to go there and [ __ ]
dance for an hour and give them a
[ __ ] private speech so they'll give
you a 300 grand right after Texas
probably about a buck 35 within that tax
bracket I would think right then you
know that they just [ __ ] in it out they
don't give a [ __ ] yeah and you were the
president you were the leader of the
free world and every one of them's got a
bigger boat than you they got a bigger
[ __ ] house than you they'd probably
call you by your first name a rock B
Rock [ __ ] it up Donny it's gonna say
it's Donal when he comes walking in Don
a hey little George Billy all right why
billionaires want to be President
good morning Billy I'm too good for
liquor and cigars oh god I miss it
I don't think about booze too much
anymore I have to go a while with cigars
I've almost caved like I just had the
great Tom papa on my podcast this past
Thursday and he said something because
he's cut off his cigar smoking not
completely but he's cut it down but he
said something that is stuck with me
because I didn't notice I was doing
about it he said I think about it every
day and I have to tell you I do I
actually I watched a video on YouTube of
the cigar bar that I used to go to in
their entire process of picking cigars
and making them and Ageing them you know
I feel like that [ __ ] guy wearing his
high school football jacket talking
about glory days all right on the
February 4th Monday morning podcast you
asked about why billionaires want to be
president yes and my theory before you
get into it was that they wanted to
change a bunch of laws to help their
businesses in the private sector that's
what I thought all right he said well I
can't speak from experience having
roughly a billion dollars short of a
billion dollars I am a philosophy
student Oh perfect
so I can pretend to know pretty well I
love it I could hang out with this
person this person's like me horribly
under-qualified yet is now gonna go you
know pontificate perfect all right he
said plate off oh Jesus
not that not the [ __ ] kids play with the
the [ __ ] guy there was he Italian
think he's Greek Plato Plato
I think he's Italian right hang on a
second let's let's look up this [ __ ]
guy plato PL ato philosopher let's see
what this guy was was he seemed with you
well Greek he was born in Greece I
thought I thought they all had the is
and I thought the I thought that was
Italian
all right Plato wrote in his classic war
the republic book 8 if you ever learn to
read I didn't know he had 8 books I
guess he has more that all democratic
people are consumed with unnecessary
appetites all right wait let's go back
Plato wrote in his classic work the
Republic that all democratic people are
consumed with unnecessary appetites so
now consider so consider now a person
with essentially infinite dude see you
read those books I'm too dumb to know
what that means are consumed with
unnecessary appetites what that would be
like I don't know I don't know what that
means other than food 3 eating too many
Snickers buzz anyway so consider now
you're a person with essentially
infinite money or more precisely
multiple billions of dollars and what
that money gives you access to if you
have anything at any time
I suspect that eventually you become
bored what is the one thing they can't
buy democratic political power is one of
the few things that isn't available to
them on demand [ __ ] are you talking
about you don't think democratic [ __ ]
politicians are just as paid for they're
all paid for that is why they want to be
president because money is not an object
and they desire more they want to be
elected because they're selfish ass hats
who like to swing that dicks around I
hate I hate that's that feminists stupid
[ __ ] opinion all these feminists
wrote these these [ __ ] theories about
dicks something they don't have right
and they think that guys are always
walking around wondering how big their
dick is versus the other guy who's got
the biggest dick in the room the only
person thinking about who has the
biggest dick in the room is someone who
wants to blow somebody and that's mostly
women and gay guys so I imagine you guys
I don't [ __ ] go to another room with
another guy and think about his dick I
don't all right
I'm more tuned into if this person's
trying to
troll me is there any passive aggression
is this person gonna [ __ ] me over that's
what I think about I am not thinking
about his [ __ ] [ __ ] little Hank
down there I don't give a [ __ ] anyway
and just swing that dicks around to
remind them so remind the rest of us
that they have everything because it is
the only thing that makes them feel
anything at all wishing all the best in
iya but you Bill can go [ __ ] yourself
now here's the thing all right here's
the thing you your description of a
billionaire is as cartoonish I would
imagine is his image of you unless he's
a self-made man that they're bored and
you know and you know money's no object
and then they just they have to do this
because they're bla bla bla bla bla
that's just sour grapes from somebody
who doesn't have a billion dollars I'm
sorry okay I've met a couple of
billionaires I met one in particular
who's one of the most amazing [ __ ]
people I ever met he was a self-made man
and came from nothing him and his I
guess two brothers all were [ __ ] dirt
poor all three of them became
billionaires in different [ __ ]
industries and I met this guy through
you know I don't wanna [ __ ] giveaway
who the [ __ ] it is but he was
sports-related and was a totally normal
[ __ ] person and after the show asked
like a bunch of great questions about
stand-up about how I went about it and
was a truly curious person sitting on a
billion dollars and did not seem bored
at all to me he was full of life in
curiosity and I only met him that one
time and in that experience stayed with
me so it's kind of like how they look at
celebrities like you know people in
Hollywood they're a bunch of [ __ ] you
know whatever [ __ ] ego maniacs and
then this and then that bla bla bla bla
bla
the little that I've done in this
business I can tell you that they work
their [ __ ] asses off they're working
their [ __ ] asses off and I know
because you see the finished product
like I tell you Don you know stand-up
comedy easy easy gig writing a TV show
editing it and [ __ ] casting it all of
that thing is an endless [ __ ] job
that literally breaks people they can
tell you I know it looks like I'm
telling you [ __ ] telling you it's
like being in the [ __ ] NFL and now
and everybody knows how much you get
beat up but everybody just oh my god
this is all fun and [ __ ] blah blah I
just look at the NBA and all those
sports leagues and how you are required
to sit down and do a [ __ ] interview
after every [ __ ] game how you have to
sit down 82 [ __ ] times and sit there
and listen and sit across from some fat
[ __ ] who can't even remotely do your job
okay
no you guys all you guys talk a good
[ __ ] game all you guys talk a good
game i'ma tell you right now there was a
[ __ ] big band you know super [ __ ]
famous they parted ways with their lead
singer this [ __ ] karaoke dude became
their lead singer alright somebody's
literally from the audience
huge fan became their [ __ ] lead
singing you know what that [ __ ] [ __ ]
did he started bitching about doing the
[ __ ] Road yeah it's [ __ ] hard it's
[ __ ] hard said all just hanging out
at the [ __ ] Chateau [ __ ] doing
blow but that is a big part of it I'm
not gonna lie to you
anyway so I'm just saying like if what I
have learned in my life here is that
that successful people work their
[ __ ] balls off and there's really no
way
to make it and then put your feet up
unless you're old enough that you feel
like you're gonna die in the next five
years because the way the game is set up
is if you stop running you're gonna get
trampled well what was that what was
that [ __ ] story about that guy who
caught that giant fish that took him all
the way out to sea and by the time he
brought it back all these fish had taken
giant bites out of it
and he had nothing left but the [ __ ]
skeleton that's what happens when you
stop running so I don't know hey maybe
this guy wants to run because he
actually thinks he can help out the
company company the country maybe he's a
patriotic guy but I think Bloomberg's
gonna get the nomination and I want to
see rogue billionaire versus rogue
billionaire pay-per-view [ __ ] debate
I want to see that because at this point
it's it's all out the [ __ ] window
it's all out the window people that are
still supporting Trump when he's so
overtly [ __ ] racist I get the ax
conservative but you know that [ __ ]
guy you know stay true to yourself to
somebody who's retweeted all of these
[ __ ] racist things and [ __ ] and
seeing you know neo-nazis and be like
well you know there's two sides to the
story I mean how you can just so I get
that you don't like Democrats but you
know you can in some level just be like
you know I don't condone him being
overtly raised I just don't understand
that part of it and it's [ __ ] really
depressing so I feel once again that if
the Democrats run a company man against
this guy they're gonna [ __ ] lose but
I think a better matchup like a boxing
match up if they're not gonna go Bernie
Sanders like the people want then I
think that you got to fight fire with
fire and get another [ __ ] crazy
billionaire in there and then they can
[ __ ] who's gonna stand up to the
bully cuz Donald Trump is a [ __ ]
bully it's kind of funny to watch the
way he Sykes them all up that scowl on
his face all right we'll see we'll see
what happens it's definitely a long shot
all right data rights and paranoia of
the future dear Billy big balls data
rights and paranoia of the future right
Oh buddy why you gonna do this to me
people I've left this [ __ ] behind this
[ __ ] does nothing for you if you [ __ ]
read up on this other than scare the
[ __ ] out of you or make you do something
crazy and then you have to leave your
own country all right dear Billy big
balls I know you don't care to follow
early politics but a candidate andrew
andrew yang talked about establishing a
data bill of rights he explained it and
well there goes his [ __ ] campaign
hopes they're gonna [ __ ] bury that
guy explained it in full and it went
right over the audience's head i think
it's the most important policy put out
there I would say the environment is
probably the number one thing and then I
yeah I would say yeah I don't think that
I think you have an entire generation a
half of people that kind of grew up
without privacy and I think they're kind
of used to it
I don't know anyways he goes am i
paranoid thinking we will face a
humanitarian crisis with corporations
sharing our data imagine your insurance
company goes up because Fitbit sold your
data to Kaiser and they didn't like your
resting heart rate well no matter what
bigger the numbers are gonna work in
their favor or a lack of physical
activity
if Geico learned that you drive 10 miles
per hour over the speed limit on your
daily commute because Samsung sold you
your GPS data or if linked-in got your
facebook private messages or phone text
messages and a computer algorithm showed
you're saying unsavory things ten years
ago so you can't get employment anywhere
or if a hacker released everyone's
search results on the internet it's
complete chaos that would ensue
I'm sorry if I made you more paranoid
than you already are but is this a
concern I've attached the data Bill of
Rights linked on this website below love
you and get some Sun you pasty [ __ ] I've
always maintained if everybody's text
mess
suja's were made public none of us could
go to work on Monday so I would think
people with that [ __ ] would be afraid to
do it on a widespread level because
eventually would come back to them and
there's no way to delete anything or
whatever blah blah blah blah blah blah I
don't know I have no idea I have no idea
but you know once everybody [ __ ] was out
there then this is a freedom of like
well you know I got no more secrets so
I'm what the [ __ ] I think what you want
to think but she it I mean I don't know
I don't know what tell you sir my
biggest thing is the [ __ ] environment
and these never-ending Wars and
switching to a different form of energy
I don't give a [ __ ] if it's if it's I
don't know just as dirty is oil just
something to get us out of the business
of going into other countries [ __ ]
with their leaders and and trying to
take their natural resources I just
don't understand that I you know you
don't listen to my [ __ ] point of view
because I don't [ __ ] watch anything I
just look at [ __ ] I think [ __ ] and then
I say [ __ ] so I don't know anything all
right
I'm not blue or [ __ ] red but I am
against somebody that is just I know
there's there's no reason if you when
you lead people you need to bring people
together I feel that's you know and when
you divide people that is it's just it
it doesn't work out for anybody all
right should I get a nose job no boy
dear Billy but lik Magoo CHH before I
start I would love to hear the lovely
Nia's advice I believe this needs a
female touch while she's downstairs
watching the Oscars so I want to tell
you before I start I would love to hear
the Luca wait good morning this is a
long one but I believe people who hear
this would like to know the full extent
of my unique slash no one gives a [ __ ]
situation so should I get a nose job oh
Jesus I just turned 18 in the past
couple of months I'm a high school
senior and I've never been laid now I'm
pretty sure I know what you thinking
bill don't get
down in the dumps because I'm 18 and a
half time however in school and the
school I'm in it's like some [ __ ] all
around orgy pretty much everyone I know
has been finger-blasting or [ __ ]
someone I've only hooked up slash made
out with two girls which I know shows
that I have potential one of these girls
was a girlfriend I had for a couple
months but broke up with her because I
didn't feel as happy as I believed I
should dude it kind of sounds to me like
you know who you are that's a very
mature thing to do anyways parenthesis I
may be 18 but I know what I want a
relationship but to be honest I believed
I could be at least have gotten a bj
from her if I hang on for a couple of
months but I didn't want to use her like
that
yeah buddy you're a good person don't
question any of this because everybody
else around you is acting like a [ __ ]
chimp
anyways I also have a big friend group
with both guys and girls I enjoy being
with them however most of them date each
other so it borders bothers the [ __ ] out
of me to not have someone for myself
while there they're always around tongue
punching which is [ __ ] with my mind
now my nose I have a gigantic hump in
the middle of my nose it sticks out like
a sore thumb and is a beacon of ugly on
my face when I was in middle school I
was bullied a lot about my nose so I'm
really sensitive about it but after
middle school had stopped
I guess everyone matured past bullying
well maybe you grew into your face I
mean you know I had a giant my head was
the same size it is now it's like
[ __ ] - he said I have a decent body
in height my face would be okay ish if I
didn't have this fat [ __ ] nose on my
face that just that's just a [ __ ]
deterrent well dude I'm telling you it's
really sharpening your [ __ ] comedic
skills here which in the long run I'm
telling you is gonna get you a lot of
ass you're gonna be fine you don't need
to [ __ ] do this [ __ ] you
not to go Kardashian on this thing this
is why I want to get surgery
I believe in 2020 I could get a fine
nose that doesn't look the way hair
plugs did in 2003 look up nose hump
surgery and see for yourself
alright you know what I'll do that in
fairness to you but I mean I wouldn't do
it it [ __ ] 18 you're crazy
you're you're super [ __ ] emotional
that that's a crazy thing to do you
don't need plastic surgery at 18 all
right I I ride this [ __ ] nose out and
tell you thirty all right and if it when
you're thirty if you're still feeling
that way and your brain is fully
developed which they're now showing
studies that it isn't until you like 27
to 30 is something like that that
somebody said to me that I overheard and
I didn't look up to see if that's true
enough but now I'm telling it to you
alright
nose hump surgery uh-huh they spell
surgery right
is there an e in there are they as it
all use au SH how much do I have to
[ __ ] pay an internet for the [ __ ]
thing to work oh it's su rger why is
that looks better right so what it is no
some surgery will not come up alright
maybe it will in a minute
yeah dude there is no [ __ ] reason in
the world for you to be you know [ __ ]
with your face okay you're in the prime
of your life
you haven't even fully developed alright
you're gonna grow into your body and
you're gonna look fine and you know
something
it's like it's the improv I know this is
a [ __ ] old person thing to say but it
really is the imperfections that make
people make people interesting you know
one of those Kardashians I don't know if
she got a ton of [ __ ] or whatever but
like she just looks like she looks like
a completely different person so and I
gotta be honest you like that that's
like when I won't look at that that's is
like depressing to me
where it's like you got a like I don't
know how much you must not like yourself
to do something like that so I would say
you know what you got to learn to love
yourself love what you look like and
there's nothing wrong with you okay dude
I'll tell you right now
I had [ __ ] orange hair if I could get
laid you don't have a [ __ ] up you're
already in there you're already in the
game alright and you're funny you're
fine you're [ __ ] fine anyways he goes
this is why I want certain I'm still
waiting for this [ __ ] thing to load
and if I did it on my goddamn phone you
know how much you by the way you know
much [ __ ] nose hump surgery spam I'm
gonna get now that I [ __ ] looked it
up anyways this is why I want to get
surgery I believe in 2020 I could get a
fine nose of over
I already looked at all this okay I'm
also under percent confident in saying
that multiple girls would have hooked up
with me if I wasn't so damn ugly cuz of
this elephant trunk of my nose I used to
think that chicks didn't hook up with me
I used to think going like if I didn't
have red hair I'd have a girlfriend and
I made that a truth in my head and guess
what it happened I'll tell you you know
what's a great way to get laid
start saying hello to people put
yourself out there and then that's it
you know you can make a self-deprecating
joke about your nose if you're feeling
that type of [ __ ] I guarantee and most
women are good man ie talking about I
think he knows it's cute they're gonna
be fine with it
anyways however the final problem is
that I believe if I get the nose job I'm
giving in like a [ __ ] and I'll lose a
piece of my pride well I agree with that
so soak in this information to help me
decide if I should get one don't there's
very few times I'm 100% positive I have
a 100% positive you should not get a
nose job at 18 okay once you do that you
cannot [ __ ] go back and I also gotta
tell you something when you do [ __ ] like
that you're gonna look a lot [ __ ]
different look at that chick from that
[ __ ] movie there where they were
dancing around right
she didn't dirty dancing and I thought
she was so [ __ ] cute not saying she
isn't now I'm not trying to [ __ ] on
anybody I'm just saying there wasn't
anything wrong with it
um anyway so I want to soak in this
information that we decide absolutely
the easiest decision ever don't you're
fine you're [ __ ] fine
all right give 35 years old and you
still want to do it then you know then
that that's something else all right
but at 18 you haven't even grown into
your body yeah yeah Jesus Christ
just [ __ ] the biggest thing you need
to work on is to get out of your own
head and think that that [ __ ] nose is
gonna hold you back all right you got to
be fine don't do it yeah me don't do it
all right overrated underrated hey Bill
underrated laying out your landscape
plants in trees so they can mature to
their natural sizes without requiring
pruning to avoid buildings and [ __ ]
that's that's pretty yeah that's pretty
smart overrated paying someone to cut
your landscaping plants and trees any
more often than necessary call them what
you want landscapers godness whatever
the point is what a waste a stupid
amount of money for a manufactured need
gruesome example but bear with me you
wouldn't keep a bunch of Rottweilers in
kennels sized four pugs then pay someone
to cut parts of the dog off to keep them
apart right Jesus Christ if you needed
them in kennels you'd put them in those
with adequate space similarity trees and
plants grow to prospective sizes if you
space them all accordingly you don't
have to pay anyone to cut them into
place maybe I'm too old no I think you
know I think you're thinking the right
[ __ ] you want a little serial killer
there with chopping up the dogs but I
think you made a point in there all
right that's the podcast everybody yeah
[ __ ] yourselves and I will check in on
you on Thursday
once again thank you to everybody came
out to casino gig at the Chumash casino
in Santa Ynez I had a great time
Dean Del Ray murdering it as always
March 10th
remember come on down
for the it's got to be it's got a rhyme
the rocket [ __ ] sock matter what the
[ __ ] it is jokes and [ __ ] rock and
roll that the Avalon in Hollywood all
right
see